this picture purports to show Kim
jong-un with a miniaturized nuclear
weapon people lasted it when it came out
last year but now if they believe this
is the real deal what does it show us
well it would suggest that this would be
about two feet across experts say it
might weigh 500 600 pounds something
like that and it would have potentially
the destructive potential of those bombs
that you mentioned which the United
States dropped on Japan seventy two
years ago this week but look at the
difference in size each of these was 10
to 11 feet long weighed around something
on 10,000 pounds these had to be carried
by a heavy bomber this is a different
thing all together in this case maybe
you are talking about something that can
fit in the nose cone of one of their
existing missiles if that is the case it
changes the game because their last
missile test went 2300 miles up into
space way above the space station way
above many satellites out there yeah it
only went 621 land miles but that's
because it basically went straight up
and came straight down some scientists
say if you flatten out that trajectory
if you fire it across the earth then you
could reach Guam you could reach Y
Alaska and some scientists say based on
the weight of the payload in theory they
could reach about half of the United
States and some major cities in here